foreign
welcome to the show
hi good afternoon thank you for taking
the call sure how can we help
okay all right I'm a little nervous so
um I'm a registered nurse and I work for
our company I'm currently on maternity
leave now but I was unfortunately
displaced um a couple months
um
after being in maternity leave I
recently have a offer from the same
company for the emergency room
um but then I also have an offer for
um the oncology Suite that I that I used
to work at but it's a different unit
it's not the same exact unit but it's
under the same management but it's
coming from like kind of like a toxic
type of management so
um and another backstory I'm also a
graduate student about to graduate for
my family and expectation in December do
I bite the bullet and go back to what I
know or do I just leave that toxic
situation and go on to Embark in the
evening for a couple months until I get
my career going
is that gonna re is is that move that
you just gave us there the second option
so not going back to the toxic
environment but taking the second option
is that going to be an interruption in
income is it going to be the same amount
of income what's that going to look like
um so it would be like a lateral thing
it will be the same pay because we're
unionized so it's the same page then I
would do that but but the [ __ ] the Ed
yeah why would you go back to toxicity
when you're not going to be there long
term anyway right
true so what's pulling you back towards
that
um
I'm gonna tell you what it is because I
want you to I want you to agree or
disagree because I may be wrong I think
it's because you would rather be
um comfortable in misery then
uncomfortable and something that you're
not that's something you don't know and
so you go oh it's miserable it's toxic
but at least I know what to expect and I
can get through it versus the change the
unknown
yes you know this I know I've heard this
call a few thousand times and it's okay
to feel that way it's natural because
the change in the unknown is horrifying
sometimes but let me just simplify it
for you do you have the ability to do
this new job and do it well
oh yeah absolutely and I'm a fast
learner you're a fast learner You Got
High character high integrity don't you
yes I do what would have to be true for
you to fail miserably at that
you'd have to do something stupid yeah
not do it uh do something stupid be lazy
dishonest none of those things are gonna
happen you know that
take that position and as you're
finishing up the credentialing and the
education piece to get you where you
want to go try a new environment
hopefully a much healthier environment
don't go back to toxicity just because
you know it great wisdom there thanks so
much for the question Keisha